The jogan Experience C Williams was just
here got to say Mark Curry remember our
guy Mark Curry [__] yeah Mark Curry's a
man Mark Curry is a sweetheart I just
bumped into him do you have his number
no I I got to get his number I got him
into the haha and then he was working a
little at the store before the pandemic
hit my man Willie D reached out to me
the other day and he said that he saw
him he said Mark Curry was on fire Mark
Curry was open enough for cat he said it
was insane it's 40 years a standup what
do you expect oh Mark was so underated
so underrated so we'd see him at the
store he was so polished but you know
what he just made a ton of money off
that show I was like I'm good I'm a
chill he's a great guy too yeah the best
nicest guy in the world nicest guy in
the world always great to Young comics
when I walk in the store he was always
very nice great to everybody you didn't
have to earn you you know a conversation
with him he talked to Door people so
Mark Curry is opening for cat on the
road yeah yeah at least that show in
Austin
and did they do the Moody I don't know
what he did did a big place though cat's
killing it it's like his ticket sales we
up like
800% they did the HB Center HB Center
yeah so they did the big place that's
that 15,000 place look at that come on
son Come On Son let's
go I always loved cat I love cat so I
don't know he did an interview he said I
wouldn't have m what are you talking
about I have I'll have you on let's go
two times anytime I have you whenever
you want to come by call me call me I'll
[__] you I'll fire this place up at 3:00
in the morning for you I'll wake
up